[Applause]
boom
hey everyone I'm Carolina and if you
know me you know I love to pick out the
best outfit for any occasion some might
say I spend a little bit too much time
scrolling on the internet for fashion
info but can you ever be too inspired I
don't think so I've been watching season
two of cbs's ghost on Paramount plus
which is about a millennial couple that
inherits a haunted house and the ghosts
of Woodstone Manor come from all walks
of life time periods and matters of
death but the one thing that unites them
all they are stuck in the clothes that
they died in
forever I wish I was wearing underwear
we all do Trevor so today I'm gonna pick
out something that I would like to wear
forever to haunt people in
the scariest part about all this is
having to find an outfit to wear forever
I don't even know what I'm gonna wear
tomorrow let alone forever it has to be
timeless flattering and comfortable damn
I ruffled Colonial Garb oh a leather
jacket maybe like a cool girl ghost
maybe not oh wait what if skinny jeans
come back I hope they don't
um oh a slip dress maybe a hot girl
ghost
oh but why would my abuelito say if he
saw me in this no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no not a good idea a
scary mask perhaps
oh
too scary
uh let's see
oh
dude let's do this
whoa
okay cute definitely flattering but not
not very comfortable it is working girl
I don't think I can sleep in this
forever and that's not good for anybody
plus I feel like it needs to be a little
bit more
[Music]
ghosty oh
my God
not bad I could change the shoes though
well this is definitely more comfortable
but is this too much of a cliche people
putting sheets over their heads and
pretending to be ghosts I mean what is
that oh I know what I'd like to try
this is more comfortable I can Vibe with
this but what if I see really cute ghost
boy I don't want to go in a cute ghost
day this is not date worthy that smart
alec question along with your incomplete
formal attire leaves you out in the cold
I need something Grand something
big
I have just the luck
[Music]
this is perfect bravo bravo I think it's
elegant it's Timeless dare I say a
little spooky thank God I died dressed
to the nine it's the perfect
[Music]
prank everyone it's just Catalina again
knocking over the flower knocking over
the candlesticks I feel like I could
definitely make a grand entrance if you
got it
haunt it I think Abuelita would approve
of this I think he'd be like you know
what elegant love it love to see it this
is the perfect dress to walk through
walls let's say I knock something over
and they're like What's that and I'm
walking through the wall and all I see
is end of my dress I think people's
first impression of me and the afterlife
would be like whoa where'd you get that
dress and it'd be like can't tell it's
my ghostly secret I would say this is a
pretty Timeless gown it's very
comfortable it's flattering and if I
need to go on a ghostly date perfect fit
if I need to go to a grand party in the
afterlife perfect fit and I always say
it's best to be overdressed than
underdressed now that I have my haunting
outfit I can go back to watching season
two of CVS's ghost on Paramount Plus
[Applause]
bye-bye
[Music]